[Applaudissements]
petit
voici à quoi ressemble un match de
roller hockey au plus haut niveau
français de prime abord on a
l'impression d'assister à une rencontre
de hockey sur glace sans glace car la
patinoire est un assemblage de dalles
plastifié et avec des roulettes sous les
patins des hockeyeurs première attaque
en
la passe au def p derrière l'entraîneur
des prédateurs de vierzon vient du
hockey sur glace il y à jouer à tour un
an tout à toulouse puis il est tout
naturellement arrivé au roller hockey
après avoir remisé ses patins bongo ont
15 aine d'années en arrière la plupart
des joueurs qui qui était dans les
équipes de roller hockey venait de la
glace c'était un sport club qui venait
de démarrer et là maintenant de par la
fondation
de par la création de la ligue élite
maintenant plus de joueurs ici
complètement du roller que dans ce genre
de place les prédateurs devient son
jouent dans le championnat élite depuis
2019 ils figurent donc parmi les dix
meilleurs clubs français mais n'ont pas
encore disputé un championnat entier les
deux dernières saisons ont été
interrompues en raison de la crise
sanitaire l'équipe est essentiellement
françaises mais il y a quelques
étrangers comme cet étudiant suédois
connexion j'ai eu un super contact avec
le club j'ai vu qu'ils avaient une bonne
équipe de bonnes recrues qui arrivait et
je me suis dit qu'on aurait des chances
de faire
et c'est le cas les prédateurs figure
parmi les cinq premiers du championnat
élite assuré de se maintenir est en
position d'accrocher le podium à la fin
de la saison
c'est une fierté pour l'ensemble du club
des dirigeants aux supporters tous de
vrais ambassadeurs de leur sport
prédateur un jour prédateurs toujours
c'est à dire que quand on vient une fois
on revient vierzon est connu pour son
équipe de roller hockey donc et puis lé
métier comme ça tourne aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux donc vierzon voyage
beaucoup aussi
grâce grâce au roller hockey des grâces
aux prédateurs
l'objectif prioritaire du club reste de
développer le roller hockey chez les
jeunes depuis la création des prédateurs
de vierzon en 1998 cette pépinière de
joueurs a toujours constitué la base des
futures équipes adultes l'encadrement
des jeunes et donc ici pris très au
sérieux sans rooney sont là on a pas de
continuité pour un club pense qu'une
école de roller est fondamental pour
tous les clubs mais pourquoi attirer le
jeune à revenir il faut leur donner
aussi une envie c'est un sport un peu de
contact et moi j'aime beaucoup ce sport
comme ça et c'est un sport aussi un peu
de précision il faut savoir shooter
précis faire des passes précis et voilà
c'est mon cousin qui m'ont mis dedans
l'ambition des prédateurs est ainsi de
contribuer à la renaissance du re larque
en france seule équipe régionale dans
l'élite française elle rêve même un jour
de ramener un titre de champion de
france à vierzon
et voilà